[Music]
honking horns a familiar sound to
canadians but this is france
trucks cars motorcycles and yes canadian
flags are out on the streets these
vehicles are a part of the european
freedom convoy apparently inspired by
actions first seen in ottawa
we saw the canadians and we said to
ourselves it's awesome what they are
doing and in eight days boom something
was triggered
it's unclear who started the european
convoy but it appears to have support
from france's yellowvest protesters in
2018 the group flooded the streets of
paris and at times clashed with police
escalations from demonstrations that
first started over rising fuel prices
i can't stand the pass anymore it's hell
says this man we must return to normal
ending all coped 19 restrictions seemed
to be one of the group's demands french
police are getting out ahead of the
convoy's arrival in paris friday
gatherings in the streets are now
prohibited between friday and monday and
citizens have been warned about
penalties for obstructing or interfering
with open roads up to two years in jail
and 4 500 euros in fines plus
immobilization and impoundment of
vehicles i'm excited
it's true that it's been said that they
cannot enter paris but i think that they
cannot block everyone from entering it's
impossible so i think they must force it
french authorities are on alert as are
officials in belgium after paris the
european freedom convoy is expected to
make its way to brussels
the headquarters of the european union
crystal gomencing global news
london